my talk of the table i am so excited
because we're talking with comedian
tiffany haddish
she just won her first grammy award for
her comedy album black mitzvah
in her netflix special of the same name
she describes
asking beyonce's mother that's tina
knowles lawson tomorrow beyonce's suit
hey miss team how you doing um
you know that suit that beyonce was
wearing that night at the party
do you think that beyonce would let me
borrow it she was like you know what's
crazy she was talking about gifting that
to you
but i don't know if you're gonna be able
to fit it you know beyonce had three
kids
and you didn't have none i was like
tiffany haddish found out that she won
the grammy for best comedy album while
filming
the cbs show that she hosts kids say the
darndest things
this is how it happened i'm just happy
with being nominated personally i've
just been nominated a couple of times
you say what that's not you've been
dominated a couple times yeah i've been
nominated a couple of times for some
things
but i just and i love i just what
you just want a grammy love being
nominated i just i just want a grammy
no i just are you are you serious i'm
not lying
i'm telling you the truth wait wait wait
wait you see y'all see this thing in my
ear
y'all seem to see my ear tell them all
you just want to grab me yeah
congratulations you just won the best
comedy outfit y'all serious
i'm serious there's no lie this is for
real
i really want well
oh gosh tiffany hattis joins us for her
first interview since winning her grammy
tiffany that's the thing we looked at
that piece yesterday and everybody got
choked up watching you
what what got you so emotional in that
moment because you could tell you were
totally caught off guard by it
well i wasn't expecting it and it was
it just was like you know how you get i
just realized how hard i've been working
and i was kind of i needed a nap at that
time
like i needed a nap and
i was almost finished interviewing those
young ladies and then
they're like you want a grammy i'm like
uh uh what
and uh my initial instinct is to cuts
and i had to turn my filter on
yeah and my filter was on
and then just the tears came out and
then i just and i looked at my
surroundings i'm like i just want in
front of these two beautiful
young african-american girls that want
to be president of the united states of
america
and i need to be uh and i was i just
wanted to
you know i don't want to mess them up i
don't want to just they're like
looking at me they can't hear the man in
my ear like oh she's just crying out of
nowhere
i know but tiffany it's so much more
than you needed a nap i know you're
going to the joke but this is the thing
look at the life that you've lived
lived and what you've accomplished and
you were in a category you were the only
woman number one
with jerry seinfeld jim gaffigan some of
the biggest
in the comedy business and you were the
one that won and what was your
message to those little girls who were
adorable looking at you it's so much
more it's
it so speaks to what you've done and how
you've accomplished it
gail i've been crying since since i
found out i went i've been crying every
like
45 minutes like a tear drop because
you know it's huge it's it's not like
for a woman to get something in that
category it's a man's world you know
yeah and for us to be able to to win
it's like i don't it's not just for me i
mean i've been through so
much in my life yeah and i always like i
feel like i have to work so
hard just to make sure like i want to
create generational wealth for my family
i want to raise up the vibration for the
whole world i want to bring joy and
happiness
i hate suffering i hate being in pain
and like
wow what an acknowledgement from my
peers that
you know we see you tiffany we're proud
of you tiffany you're doing a good job
like because i mean you guys are just
talking about instagram i get beat up so
much on on
social media you know i'm just like i'm
so glad my mom was the way that she was
because i wouldn't have
my my my soul wouldn't be able to handle
what happens on that social media realm
it's really
i'm so like it is brutal yeah
you got to be strong in the spirit yeah
tiffany so you know you didn't just win
in a man's world
i mean you're the first black woman to
win a grammy in that category
since whoopi goldberg back in 1986
and only four women in the history of
that category have ever won
four four what does that say to you
we gotta do better we gotta do better
um and that oh
we gotta do better and i'm gonna i'm
gonna drop
more comedy albums yes yes please do
yes hey tiffany uh you've got a
foundation
uh that is going to be launching an
internship program
next year i believe or it might be this
year actually it's called she ready and
what
is she ready
thank you ladies i appreciate the
translation
that is the name of the foundation
what's interesting about it is
it's focused uh on people with a
background like
yours people have had contact with the
foster care
system why is it so important for you to
help those folks
get ahead well to me it's super
important because
um you know one person believing in you
one person giving you an opportunity can
change your whole
entire trajectory you know um there's
uh i i talk to kids all the time that
are in group homes and
in different foster care situations we
get on zooms and all this and
and and talking to them they're like
yeah i just want to be an actress
or i want to be a director because or
they think there's nothing else you can
do
in the entertainment industry i'm like
no wait you can be a manager you can be
an
agent you can be a writer you can be a
gaffer you can be
a dp you can be the camera operator
there's so many there's so many choices
opportunities and so many ways to grow
tiffany that people don't know about but
this is the thing can i just say this
about you
because at this time in your life your
personal life is going great your
professional life is going great when
you in common started dating
people just said huh how is that going
to work
but yet it's working between the two of
you what makes your relationship with
him so special
yeah he allows me to be myself
i think most of my relationships haven't
worked in the past because the
men that i've dated always tried to like
dim my light or make me be smaller
and he doesn't do that he doesn't tell
me to turn my light off he lets me shine
lets me be myself which one which makes
me want to be
better yeah and like yeah
and he's kind to me he's so kind i
haven't experienced that
much in relationships kindness it's a
wonderful thing tiffany you certainly
deserve it he is one of the nicest human
beings as you said kind thoughtful smart
and not for nothing cute
and the two of you are having yeah
that's the other part i like looking at
them
you're having a great time you should
mention we've been talking about we've
been mentioning her life until
now uh you know handily enough she wrote
a memoir about that 2017 it came out
people can pick it up and get the whole
background
happy for you both and thank you for
getting up early now you can go back to
bed you still got on your pajamas
thank you tiffany thank you very much
thank you now i got to go to work in two
hours but you owe me lunch girl yes
done done